الى تطورات في السودان حيث تجددت
الاشتباكات صباح اليوم بين الجيش السوداني
وقوات الدعم السريع في مواقع مختلفه من
العاصمه الخرطومه وافاد مراسل الجزيره
بسماع اصوات انفجارات في وسط الخرطوم وبعض
احياء وسط وجنوب مدينه اندرمان كما اشار
المراسل الى تحليق كثيف للطائره الحربيه
وسماعه اصوات للمضادات الارضيه من مواقع
قوات الدعم السريع بعدد من احياء جنوب
وتاتي هذه التطورات الميدانيه بعد 24 ساعه
من توقيع الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم
السريع على اتفاق جدا لوقف اطلاق النار
نقل الاعلام العسكري يتابع لجيش السوداني
مقاطع مصوره لما وصفه بسيطره قواته على
مناطق السوق العربي والرميلا وابو حمامه
وسط الخرطوم واشار ضباط تحدثوا في المقاطع
المصوره عن تمكلهم من تمشيط مواقع كانت
تسيطر عليها سابقا قوه الدعم السريع في
السوق العربي ومحيطه الواقعه جنوب القصر
الرئاسي بالخرطوم